but never never four thousand
okay pukiri gambit
uh an indian always
uh appreciate the um profile picture
pictures of me um being the um
egomaniac that i am um and let's
try and play a bit of an unusual style
here like usually that night goes to
to f6 obviously
but trying trying something
[Music]
something else here
d5 is a good move
probably have to go c5 in order to take
away the
d4 square dc6 knight c6 i'm not too
unhappy about that
but in general i'm worse obviously
but it's may not be that bad like
knight d7 knight t5 may come
um the pawn on f5
is has its strengths and and
its weaknesses but
it's not it's it's not awful
it's usually what i'm i'm shooting for
not awful
maybe it is awful who knows could be
awful
uh anyway a6 here um
not i'm not hinting at
b5 so much as just saying i'm going to
play b5
but first let me go
bishop f5 uh i missed knight h4 though
knight h4 could be nasty i have to
exchange
some pieces this one i was not worried
about because after ef6
um and the subsequent bishop d7
and f5 i feel like i'm not doing too
badly positionally speaking
um yeah rookie 2 is a good move
could go bishop f g4
exchange and then f5 okay let me
let me try and exchange one rook first
and probably queen f8 yeah i should be a
little bit careful
because as i was talking about
in in the recent banker game
long term long term these structures are
not bad for me
um especially in this case i i
look to exchange
bishops and then later on
i feel like in the ending
[Music]
that's going to be favorable for me
because his bishop
his pawns are all on the square of um
on the color of of his of his own bishop
so
this means that his bishop doesn't have
a lot of scope
and potentially i could code b4 here
later on
um trying to cement a2 as a weakness
there is of course a danger that
the position is going to be too closed
which is not a surprise considering that
there is not a huge difference here in
in our positions but
i do have some prospects here of
um of uh playing for an advantage
this may be a blunder
yeah i think this is a blunder i do
so the knight is sort of semi-trapped
here on h2
i don't think it actually matters
because i'm
my king is so active now pg one runs
into king e3
yeah and my opponent is very little time
as well
now the knight escapes and i'm two pawns
up with um with a much better position
to boot
i'll take uh then i'll go oh
okay that was a good move i missed this
one but i do have a winning tactic still
uh if you could have gone if you could
i've gotten
canary and now it's made in three more
roofs
um um
if yeah if you could have gotten d6
there with it um without me
winning immediately he might have had
some kind of play but the way it
happened
it was not to be